the jurogan experience i would have
really loved to have seen jorge masada
and camaro usman of jorge at a camp
because he did not have a camp for that
fight and still presented some real big
problems for camaro
don't you find the ascension of jorge
kind of funny i love it i went to it do
you remember when he fought alaikum
at 1 55 i do so i was at that fight it
was in fairfax virginia and i'll never
forget
fight week was at one of these ufc gyms
in uh somewhere in the suburbs of dc i
don't remember where i live in city
property so i had to like
you know go out to the suburbs and uh it
was decently attended it was not a super
well attended um
open workout there was you know there
was enough people there and al got a
huge you know whatever
and uh i think it was frankie no it was
um chad mendes and ricardo llamas in the
main event
and uh chad was a big alpha male guy at
the time and you know he got a big
applause
jorge came out and
maybe 10 people knew who he was media
the the latin media that was there
wanted to talk to him but like
most of the media you know was kind of
like give or take on it
and i remember thinking to myself i'm
like do you do you all not know how
[ __ ] good this guy is
by the way i thought he won that fight
too and then years later crowd did as
well remember
yeah and then i was like you're gonna
[ __ ] boo me
but you know to see later it's like it's
amazing it's like you're nothing you're
nothing you're nothing all of a sudden
something well you know the resurrection
you know he talks about how he went on
that stupid reality show where they made
him live in the jungle for a couple of
weeks
yeah whatever it was and he was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing with my life
and then he had a chance to think about
all those fights where he just fell
short and why did he fall short you know
what did he do was he playing it safe
he decided he's going to start baptizing
people as he puts it
and man you talk about a guy who turned
the corner and changed i mean
the ben askren fight though that was it
that was the cherry on top and then of
course
the the murking of nate diaz i mean he
beat the [ __ ] out of nate diaz i mean
that was a crazy fight and
they were talking about running that
back i was like for
what yeah i was confused i was like
don't forget darren till put his lights
out too
yes with a beautiful step forward left
hook combination
i mean he's a monster he's a monster
he's hard for anybody to deal with and
the fact that he stopped darren till
when darren till was this
terrifying striker that just beat down
donald cerrone
you know daryntell was a scary guy and
to see him
put him away that way and you know
obviously was after tyron had beaten him
but it was still like a stunning
stunning ko
and he's just a fun guy
like everything's fun about him talk
like like i had him on the podcast and i
said
the real question is whether or not uh
ben asked can get a hold of you he's
like
he can get a hold of these nuts that's
that's him you know i mean that's him
he's just a real
fun dude he's a fun dude to watch fight
he's a fun dude to listen to him talk
he's been he can do uh he sort of cut
you off but like uh dan levitt is a big
national sports radio guy based out of
miami so there's a couple of miami
guys couple cuban americans and they're
on opposite sides politically
very much so oh he's all trump right
yeah super dan libertas very left but
like i
i they have this camaraderie through
heritage and identity and sort of shared
experiences you just can't fake you know
yeah he's awesome i'm a big fan but i'm
a big fan of him skillfully
i think he's a really exceptional
fighter he's very clever
he also has a very unusual stance like
he stands straight up
like he stands like a muay thai fighter
and one of the reasons why is his
takedown defense is so good he's
confident that he could stand straight
up like that
and his striking is very crisp very
clean and he's clever
like he sets traps he you know he
catches you like that [ __ ] ben askren
thing was goddamn genius and when you
see him prep for it
when you watch the training footage that
he did that over and not only that he
prepped for the angle
right leaned against the cage so he like
presented this
and then turned the corner went to the
right and then
charged at him so that ben ascher would
like i'm just going to grab this guy
like literally
he he set two different traps the
running at him
and then the turning the corner and then
running at him and ben asked her like
instincts just dove in and he couldn't
help himself i call it the jorge maswall
test go through any of his fights
pre till win or lose doesn't matter and
watch how many times when
you know they're getting the mouthpiece
put in and the vaseline put on at the
beginning watch how many times the
commentator says
folks don't understand how good he is
folks don't know how smart he is
this is one of the most well-rounded
fighters in all the ufc and they do it
in this kind of way to like almost
plead with the audience to understand
the fighter as they do yeah that would
be me
brian stan's done in a million times the
thing is if you and bryan stand are
doing and you're not coordinating it
something is happening here well i
remember when he knocked out eve edwards
with a head kick
when eve edwards is one of the best 155
pounders of the world after
eve edwards had beaten josh thompson
who's another guy who doesn't get
nearly the respect that he deserves the
first guy to ever knock out nate diaz
right
i mean josh thompson at one point in
time was the [ __ ] man
right and so he knocks out eve edwards
in beaudog remember beau dogs i have all
the dvds at home
i have them all at home episodes of the
joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love